-Let´s get to the news.
After Hillary Clinton
joked last night
that she was considering
dressing up as president
for Halloween,
Donald Trump Jr. tweeted,
"That´s cute.
She can borrow
my Donald Trump mask."
[ Laughter ]
Huh.
That´s Donald Trump Jr.
Just a chill, normal dude,
who owns --
who owns a mask
of his father´s face.
[ Laughter ]
"I love you, Don Jr.!"
The White House released
the official portraits
of President Trump
and Vice President
Mike Pence today.
And they put one of Steve Bannon
out on the front stoop.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
In an interview yesterday,
White House Chief of Staff
John Kelly said the Civil War
was caused by a lack
of ability to compromise.
Even weirder,
he said that Pearl Harbor
was an air-traffic-control
issue.
[ Laughter ]
I don´t know why we ever thought
there was a reasonable person
working in Trump´s White House.
That´s like going
into a Hot Topic
and asking to meet
their rocket scientist.
[ Laughter ]
A White House official
confirmed today
that President Trump
will not visit
the Korean demilitarized zone
during his upcoming trip
to Asia.
In fact, to prevent
an international incident,
Trump´s aides will
just take him to Panda Express
and tell him it´s Asia.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"Their English...
You know,
I just got back from Asia,
and their English is very good."
[ Laughter ]
"Also, do you know
they have an Asia at LaGuardia?"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
Mitch McConnell is the nation´s
least popular Senator,
which explains the festivities
over at Ted Cruz´s office.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Engineers at Ford recently
created a robotic butt --
a robotic butt --
designed to simulate
the effect of sitting in
a car seat for over a decade.
Said designers, "Right.
That´s why we made it."
[ Laughter ]
"Who left the robot butt out?"
-[ Laughing ]
-Do you like that, Wally?
You´ve enjoyed
robot butt all day.
[ Laughter ]
There´s no time today that I´ve
told the robot butt joke
that Wally
hasn´t laughed the loudest.
[ Laughter ]
Today was Christopher Columbus´
birthday,
and if you´re wondering
what to get him,
how about something that already
belongs to someone else?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Chipotle offered
$3 burritos today
to any customers who ordered
in their Halloween costume.
Good news
for the front of the horse,
but terrible news for the back.
[ Laughter and applause ]